each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
let me talk about why we care about HIV
it's one of the deadliest pandemic sin
in history treatments are effective in
the first world but in the third world
they're very complicated and not really
effective so we want to do something for
the disease for now most the people who
have it we have to come up with
something like a vaccine but vaccines
are difficult because HIV mutates not
just like I know seasonal fuel flu
mutates but it actually mutates in the
body of the patient to make itself more
deadly over its course in a single
patient so hypothesis in our group and
in general is that there are a few spots
of vulnerability this is the DNA of a
map of the DNA of HIV a few spots of
vulnerability in the DNA and they depend
on the immunity types of the patient if
our immune system just kind of goes on
its own to try to learn how to it to
come up with some attacks on the DNA
it'll pick what's basically random spots
and those aren't likely to be the spots
where the HIV is actually vulnerable if
we have a whole protein vaccine that
will train up our immune system it will
still just train be training up our
immune system at spots within what it
covers and those also aren't likely to
hit the parts of vulnerability and that
would be like The Merck vaccine what we
want is a vaccine that specifically
targets the areas where we think there's
one er abilities to train up the
patient's immunity the person's immune
system so that they can be ready to
fight the vaccine if they get it
either the virus if they get it and we
have some evidence that this approach
can work this is data from the kind of
famous Merck vaccine trial on the bottom
is the number of places where the
vaccine help the patient attack the
virus and here is the amount of virus in
the patient's blood you can see there's
no real relationship here nothing
visible but if we take a look at the
predicted vulnerability points and these
are points that our group predicted were
vulnerable before the Merc results were
available we see that in cases where we
predicted there were no vulnerability
points covered by the Merck vaccine the
Veck the HIV the virus load was very
high and in the places where there was
one vulnerability predicted by our
results the virus load was lower so this
gives us hope that we're on the right
track so let me I'll start or I'll
continue by talking about our group a
big part of our group is scaling so I'll
talk about how we kind of just practical
experience in scaling across processors
computers users and very briefly users
and computers and then finally just one
slide of the web tools that we've open
sourced or I mean that the applications
we've either made available as web tools
or open source or in most cases both so
we're a small group we're applying
computer science to other branches of
science and health energy water
management and so on we tend to partner
with experts who have the wet labs in
clinics Los Alamos Harvard Medical
School that's nicer to at least I
personally I'm glad we don't have wet
labs there in redmond the part of the
group that's working on these kind of
HIV and does
related projects include david hackman
jennifer lewis garden jonathan carlson
bob davidson most old Bob and David here
and nuh bosha and the goal of the group
is to produce first and foremost
scientific progress in the form of
treatments and is measured perhaps by
journal articles we produce software
tools that we can share and we also
serve a useful function by giving
feedback to other parts of Microsoft on
what scientific users need from their
software so the part of the group that
i'm in started out as part of the
machine learning group and a lot of what
we do is create new statistical
algorithms that exploits something that
previous statistical algorithms didn't
have and that's just tremendous amounts
of computation in the past there were
often kind of theoretical ideas in
statistics that if hypothetically you
could say look at lots and lots of
permutations you could set some value
but it wasn't practical to do it kind of
in that theoretical way well now that
that that theoretical approach has
become practical in many cases so we're
exploiting both increases increasing
amounts of data and increasing amounts
of computation and of course like any
statistical software the purpose is
always to get more the most signal that
we can from the data and this second
thing of course is supply these tools to
all interested users so let's look at
one problem we had and kind of the tools
we use to approach we use to solve it so
we have a program not yet shared called
I constr at covariance and kind of what
it sounds like it does if you have a lot
of patients say a thousand patients for
every pair of patients you want to come
up with a single real number that
expresses the similarity of those two
patients as measured by how much they
have in common in their DNA
run typically if you just kind of run it
the normal way would take three hours
and that's kind of boring you have to
start working on a whole nother project
you lose track your productivity goes
down we'd really like if we have an
eight processor machine to get the
result 86 times faster something like
that and what we found very useful is
parallel extensions and basically it's a
we'll see in a second what that is so
it's a new standard component of net
it'll be coming out in Visual Studio
2010 but it's a version of its now
available as a technology preview it's
whole point is to make the easy things
easy I think there's been a lot of work
in parallel programming to make the hard
things possible and what we're
discovering is there's so much easy
stuff that it's important to make that
simple to do we use it primarily at kind
of the first and last steps of the kind
of programs we write a lot of times
there's either preparation work data
cleaning or some kind of summarization
step that is not practical to run on
lots and lots of machines that kind of
has to run on one machine perhaps
because it needs quick access to all the
data and it's nice to you can be using
all your say eight processors to do that
and let me just give a simple example
suppose we just have a 2d array and we
want to find the mean of every row kind
of regular C sharp programming is here
we just loop over the Rose I and then
for each column in J we total things up
and then we find the mean for each row
so at the parallel extension library
here's the change we have to make we've
basically only changed one line now we
just say parallel for the only thing you
have to do to be careful here is we have
to be sure we put our results in a
pre-allocated array of doubles and that
and these pre-allocated arrays are
thread safe so we can just
be putting in the results as they come
in in any order and we'll have the
results there in a parallel the pole
parallel extensions library has many
many components but we basically find
three to being to do ninety nine percent
of what we want parallel for which is
this is an example for of there's
parallel for each which works exactly
the way you'd expect it to work given
that you've just seen parallel four and
one very interesting other feature which
is more different and has some
additional power parallel link so with
parallel link you can create a for each
kind of statement you can do groupings
where tests like we saw in the previous
talk the nice thing is about it you
don't have to have a pre-allocated place
for your output it'll do the work in
parallel but it'll give you the results
in a single sequence kind of one at a
time as it as they're finished so let's
look at another problem Philo D is a
program for finding associations between
viral DNA and some other factor like a
user's immunity type
it's a typical run can take a CPU year
and that's too long even on eight
processors so for that we run it on the
HPC and we have a library that makes
things a little more convenient I'll
talk about that briefly so so one
version of philo d is just this just
this command line program say 50 d you
give it the DNA of the HIV you give it
this phylogenetic tree this tree of
family relations between the DNA
sequences you tell the HLA of the
patients that you're giving it the data
for and you give it an output file
what's so this is just something you can
run on a regular machine right at the
command line what's nice is that it's
delightfully parallel every line of
output in the final report is
independent of every other line so to
make this run on the HPC we just have to
change it in kind of a MapReduce way
with just as a programmer just making
supporting a few additional command-line
arguments first task count so you have
to add code to tell it how to break the
work up into a thousand hearts and then
tasks you have to tell it what parts
this particular run of it should be
working on so we tell it we had the code
that break so we can break work into a
thousand parts and in this case we want
it to work on part 22 and we change the
output file to have some kind of pattern
thing there so then we get these
thousand output files they won't all
have the same name and finally we code
something when we type dash cleanup and
all that has to do is merge the
different output files and that might
just be merging the output lines
literally or sometimes there's a more
reduced kind of thing where there's some
statistical analysis done but relatively
quick compared to the production of the
output
the simplest case the HPC already comes
with a relatively nice graphical user
interface and if you have a job set up
like this you can just tell it to run
the thousand jobs to divide the work and
one job to combine the results and we
also have a library and if you link into
our library you can just added one
command and the minimum dash cluster we
tell if the cluster and the where you
where the data is on that cluster if
they're the same place and with just
that additional command your job that
did run on your own desktop now can run
on the cluster eventually get the
results and have your in this case
single output file waiting for you on
the file share so we had another program
this program only takes like 15 minutes
to run it's called create epitome it
merges amino acid sequences together to
create a short vaccine that gives you as
much coverage as you decide is
worthwhile so our problem was we wanted
to make this we wanted to make this a
web app and 15 minutes per user doesn't
seem that bad but if a dozen users start
using it all at the same time and you're
running it just as a web app then the
web service then the web server is going
to start complaining and your web hoster
is going to tell you can't run your app
Anene more here so in this case we wrote
it we created a version of it in
silverlight here's a snapshot this works
nicely it from the users point of view
it's a web app runs on macs or pcs under
IE or firefox you still have a GUI
that's as nice as pretty much as nice as
a desktop GUI especially good from a
programming point of view is adding the
Silverlight making the silverlight
version
and since the original code was in
c-sharp was basically almost no extra
code and we had to write code for the
GUI but that was useful for the desktop
also and best of all it now does the
actual 15 minutes of computation on the
user's machine instead of on our web
server finally just one thing was
alluded to this morning you also have
the scenario where you have perhaps
hundreds of users and you want to run on
hundreds of processors what do you do
then we now have we told available a
version of philo d running on is running
on a year that addresses this as an
alternative to you sending your data to
David or me or Jonathan and having us
run it for you so just list the catalog
of the things that we have available out
there more things there we have programs
and applications coming out all the time
at a concluding statement that their new
statistical methods powered by
increasing computation for fighting HIV
and other diseases the thing that powers
this ability to use increasing
computation is the ability that the
libraries like parallel extensions HPC
silver lightness or give us to kind of
efficiently code up these new programs
and for more info there's a link to all
the bio apps and you can go to my web
page which is a little easy to remember
and you can see the codeplex and the web
pages thanks Carl
you